encuentre el valor de posición de 3 en
4.356 y cada vez que pienso en el valor
de posición y mientras más practiquen
problemas sobre esto será un poco más
automático cuando veo un problema como
este sobre lo que realmente es gastar
4.356 entonces voy a volver a escribir
los números lo haré en distintos colores
entonces 4.356 es igual a y piensan en
la forma en que dije eso es igual a 4000
+ 300
más 300 más 50
+ 6 y llegamos a lo que ya dijimos 4.356
ahora otra forma de pensar en esto si
esto es como decir cuatro miles
4 miles
más
tres cientos
+ 5 decenas
+ 6 y en lugar de 6 podrían decir 6 1
entonces volvemos al número original
4.356 esto es lo mismo que cuatro mil
305 decenas y luego 61
5 decenas
y luego 6 unos
entonces cuando preguntan cuál es el
valor de posición de 3 en 4.356 nos
interesa este 3 acá y su valor de
posición está en la posición de los
cientos si hay un 4 son 400 si hay un 5
serán 5 cientos es la tercera desde la
derecha este es el lugar de los 16 unos
5 decenas 300 entonces la respuesta aquí
está en la posición de los cientos